[Música]
voy a contaros algo que me pasó
un día de octubre del año 1966
era última hora de la tarde
y era
en un autobús escolar
yo era un niño de 6 años
en el autobús regresaba de la escuela a
casa mi casa era la última del trayecto
por lo tanto me aburría
y decidí abrir sobre mis rodillas un
cuento que ese día la señorita la
profesora nos había repartido a todos
los alumnos de párvulos estaba
enseñándonos a leer
en la parte superior de cada página
había un dibujo en la parte inferior una
línea de letras conformaban unas
palabras que nos dijo ella qué
significaban lo mismo que el dibujo
representaba
posee mi vista sobre esa línea de letras
y súbitamente creí entender algo
de lo que decía esa sucesión de letras
hacia la vista al dibujo
coincidía coincidía el sentido de lo que
yo había querido captar con el dibujo y
en ese momento exacto y preciso fui
consciente de que había sucedido algo
extraordinario había aprendido a leer
sabía leer
era lector
lo que yo no podía saber en ese momento
que recuerdo perfectamente me conmocionó
hasta tal punto que lo recuerdo todavía
pero lo que yo no podía saber es que ese
hecho me había
traspasado me había hecho cruzar un
umbral de una puerta
cuyo nombre he descubierto con el paso
de los 52 años que han seguido esa
puerta se llama inmortalidad
la primera pista al respecto de esta
cuestión me dio una frase hace unos años
de william shakespeare
la frase dice estamos hechos de la
materia de los sueños
la materia de los sueños los sueños que
son los sueños los sueños son las
historias los cuentos ese cuento que te
contó tu padre o tu madre al pie de la
cama ha de irte a dormir
lo que hoy esté decir a un vecino o un
tío una tía lo que te contaron los
amigos todo lo que has leído desde que
sabes leer
lo que has escuchado en la radio esa
obra de teatro
esa película en el cine o en la
televisión todas esas historias son los
sueños y te conforman porque si estamos
hechos de carne de sangre de huesos pero
no sólo de carne sangre y huesos estamos
hechos estamos hechos también de
historias de sueños ayer casualmente
cayó en mis manos un libro sobre la
guerra civil española contiene la carta
que una enfermera remitía a sus
superiores pidiéndoles gasas algodón
pinzas yodo para ese hospital en el que
comparecían jóvenes soldados cura
heridas de guerra con brazos y piernas
amputados
y pedía algo sabiendo que prácticamente
no había de nada de todo lo demás que
subrayaba mucho ella en esa carta libros
y lo argumentaba decía ese soldado que
se recupera convaleciente de una gran
herida si lee
se abstrae de tal modo está de tal modo
en otro lugar que la herida cicatriza
más rápido lo dice una enfermera y añade
la lectura es curativa me parece una
metáfora extraordinaria de esa fusión de
lo que somos materia sangre carne y
huesos historias y sueños ensoñaciones
lo somos desde siempre yo somos de
siempre desde esa hoguera que ardía
a la entrada de una cueva en torno al
que un grupo de personas escuchan a una
de ellas contar una historia de memoria
desde que miramos la pared pintada de
esa cueva y interpretamos leemos una
historia como ahora lo hacemos cuando
nos ponemos una serie de netflix
porque somos un animal que lee somos un
animal que lee el mundo lo lee todo
continuamente
alzamos la vista al firmamento nocturno
y en el remoto pasado agrupamos las
estrellas más brillantes para que nos
cuenten una historia el zodiaco
mirábamos
el contorno de una nube
los convencemos de que era eran los
rasgos de nuestra madre muerta o
mirábamos el perfil recortado de una
montaña contra el cielo y naturalmente
que veíamos el rostro de un dios
recostado
somos historias nos contamos historias
con sus historias fabricamos historias
nos hacemos las historias encima todo el
tiempo desde siempre desde hace miles de
años
y hace sólo ocho mil años que no es nada
y veamos un sistema de signos para
primero contar las cabezas de ganado de
un rebaño o los sacos de grano en el
almacén
pero más allá de esa cuestión práctica
alguno de nosotros tuvo una idea
utilizar el sistema de signos para fijar
un cuento una historia y después otra y
otra y otra había nacido la escritura y
había nacido y sobre todo la literatura
en tablillas de barro
eso fue hace ocho mil años un tiempo
después hace cuatro mil años
alguien de nosotros ideó algo mucho más
refinado un código de signos que
permitían almacenar todas las historias
alfabeto se llama era un modo de
externalizar la memoria biológica que no
todo descanse en las circunvoluciones
cerebrales que haya una prótesis esa
prótesis se llama tablilla de barro
pergamino papiro hoja de papel en un
libro pendrive
esa prótesis
fijaos que eso fue hace cuatro mil años
hace solo dos mil quinientos años en
atenas un hombre habla un grupo de
discípulos le atiende y uno de ellos
escribe platón que haces pregunta al
maestro y platón le dice a su maestro
sócrates escribe lo que dices y que
sepas que ahora todos los jóvenes de
atenas estamos aprendiendo el alfabeto
para escribir y leer lo escrito y sabéis
lo que dijo sócrates la cultura ha
muerto
porque para eso trate de la cultura
consistía en la capacidad humana de
memorizar miles y miles de versos como
habían hecho todos los poetas de antes
de homero hasta un mero mismo y
cualquier otra cosa que aligerará esa
capacidad era reblandecer
el cerebro humano y la capacidad de la
cultura humana
500 años después en roma' un hombre que
ha vivido en roma' toda su vida como
jurisconsulto como orador como poeta
decide retirarse a su pueblo natal en
hispania
se llama marcial y ese pueblo es
bílbilis de calatayud y la dolores sin
sal se retira a pastar a sus últimos
años de vida en una casita en el campo
con un jardín un huerto y un día
este hombre marcial recibe la visita de
un amigo desde roma que le dice marcial
marcial
ese rollo de papiro en el que tú siempre
has escrito está siendo ahora sustituido
en roma por un artefacto nuevo son unas
cuartillas cuadrangulares en la que en
las que se escribe luego se relegan por
uno de los bordes se les ponen unas
tapas duras l'hivern
se llama el libro ya no vas a tener
necesidad de enrollar ese ese papiro
como un salchichón y meterlo en el
anaquel de la biblioteca y sabéis lo que
dijo marcial ante esta innovación ante
esta novedad dijo marcial la literatura
ha muerto porque para él ese cambio de
soporte significaba algo apocalíptico
cuál es la lección amigos
sócrates marcial no tenéis razón la
cultura nunca unidad la literatura nunca
morirá porque va con la bestia está en
nosotros va con el animal que somos que
leemos y que ideamos maneras y fijar
historias y ahora os diré algo
contagiando medel del conservadurismo
reaccionario de sócrates y de marcial os
diré el libro creo yo que el libro es la
tecnología más sofisticada que el ser
humano ha ideado para almacenar
historias
estoy convencido de ello coge tu libro
avanza en la historia haciendo pasar sus
páginas
retrocede en la historia retrocediendo
en sus páginas creados en un pasaje de
la historia durante una hora entera si
queréis como un helicóptero sobre una
línea subraya la anota que algo que se
os ocurre en un margen dibujar algo
doblar de la esquina de una página entre
sus páginas esconder el pétalo de una
rosa o escupir sobre sus páginas si
queréis o arrojar el libro con toda
vuestra fuerza contra el suelo y seguirá
funcionando
el libro el libro yo era un niño que
leía yo lo he dicho aprendí a leer
mi padre irrumpió en la habitación y
decía apaga la luz no leas deja de leer
tiene solo dos ojos para toda la vida te
vas a quedar ciego
y obedecía apagaba la luz pero cuando
voy a dejarse sus pasos por el pasillo
bajo las sábanas encendió una linternita
y seguía leyendo papá ciego no me he
quedado pero dios dio trias y cada ojo
si me las ha ganado
y así leyendo esos libros he sido un
niño descalzo las orillas del
mississippi me llamado tom sawyer he
sido un niño sobre una base acompañando
un negro fugitivo esclavo y asido
huckleberry finn y dejándome arrastrar
por las corrientes en otra balsa que se
llama con tyc y he llegado a una isla
remota del pacífico ya no pagado y no
fregado pero me he salvado llamándome
robinson en otra isla y es sabido que la
palabra mar contiene todos los mares del
mundo todos los seres invisibles que
nadan bajo las profundidades abisales y
los visibles que cabalgan en las espumas
y es sabido que en la palabra amar están
también todos sus abogados sin nombre
era un niño que leía
yo os diría no le digáis nunca a un niño
porque si le decís a un niño lee le
robas la magia
porque eso es un misterio es un hallazgo
ese encuentro no se puede ordenar tiene
que suceder hable acerca de esto con
roberto calasso uno de los últimos
eruditos europeos vivos que me dijo
incluso el dedo índice señalando un
libro es contraproducente y lo dígitos
que hacemos como incitamos a nuestros
hijos a leer bueno me dijo siempre a
libros por la casa deja los descuidados
reza para que el espíritu sople sobre la
cabeza de tus hijos
porque el espíritu sopla cuando y donde
quiere
bueno en mi soplo yo leía leía y leía
algunas tardes teniendo unos diez años
de edad en casa de mi abuelo mi abuelo
había nacido en un barranco en la sierra
de la alpujarra al sur de granada'
pastor labriego analfabeto
y una tarde levanté los ojos de ese tv o
libro que estaba leyendo y vi que me
miraba yo entonces no lo entendió y lo
sé me miraba con admiración porque tenía
un nieto que leía
y ese hombre no había podido queriendo
probablemente leer
no no había podido ese hombre estaba
hecho de silencios se hallaba siempre no
hablaba nunca era el silencio mismo pero
esa noche antes de acostarnos habló y
dijo una frase una sola frase dijo y
dijo
sabiendo yo después por cierto que yo
era el primero de mi genealogía que
había leído un libro porque mis cuatro
abuelos eran analfabetos
mis padres no pero no han leído libros
soy el primero de mi árbol genealógico
que ha leído un libro
y esa noche mi abuelo habló y dijo yo
pude salvar a lorca
no entendí el sentido de esa frase
pasaron los años me guru murió pero esas
palabras esas son las palabras esas
pocas palabras resonaron en mi de tal
manera que acabé indagando investigando
viajando pisando la tierra en que nació
hasta hasta encontrar descubrir contarme
su historia la historia de mi abuelo y
convertirla en qué
él nunca lo sabrá
pero esa mirada la admiración hacia su
nieto hacia ese niño que leía movió a
ese niño muchos años después
a inmortalizar a ese hombre ese hombre
anónimo analfabeto que hubiera quedado
olvidado para siempre en la oscuridad de
la historia no era nadie ahora os digo
una cosa es inmortal porque está en un
libro lo convierte en protagonista de un
libro junto a otro hombre que leía y al
que él vio leer federico garcía lorca
y documentando me respecto encontré un
discurso que dio federico garcía lorca
en fuentevaqueros su polo natal el día
en que inauguró la biblioteca de ese
lugar año 31 puede que la primera
biblioteca pública de españa y dijo
federico garcía lorca si yo fuera pobre
y tuviera mucha hambre no pediría un pan
entero pediría medio pan y un libro
porque más pena me da que el hombre que
tiene mucha hambre el hombre que quiere
saber y no puede porque el hombre que
tiene mucha hambre siempre encontrará un
mendrugo de pan unas frutas que comer
pero el hombre que quiere saber no puede
sufre cada uno de los días de su vida y
ese era mi abuelo valores ahora lo
entiendo
bien por eso porque yo he convertido en
inmortal a mi abuelo quiero compartir
ese secreto con vosotros lo que yo no
sabía en el momento en que aprendí a
leer en ese autobús pero luego he
aprendido luego es sabido luego
descubierto y es que la literatura
contiene el don de la inmortalidad así
que os digo contar las historias de las
que venís
contar las historias que os han hecho
contar la historia que estáis siendo
convertir es la materia en sueño
seréis eternos seres inmortales si hay
algo que pervive por siempre es algo
como bien dijo shakespeare son los
sueños muchas gracias
[Aplausos]